hi this is a general going to be a
general talk to anyone who may wish
to you know just listen you can close
your eyes and listen to all the way
through or just sit there and watch
watch me uh I'm currently getting over
an illness so I'll apologize if my voice
is a little bit croaky or not not as
smooth as it should be but um a student
asked me if I could help
him
understand um a little bit more about
himself and I've written four books and
I'm writing one at the
moment and uh the heading of this
particular film is called a bucket full
of
jeans and that's where I'd like to start
and talk about
it uh I like a lot of the world suffer
from depression and I have done ever
since I can remember even from a young
boy I get very low periods and then I've
now learned that uh it's a little bit
like just waiting for a bus that isn't
on time so in the end you just have to
to wait and like the depression I've
learned that it will go it always has
done yes you go through very low
times and it would be nice if it goes
quicker but you can't seem to rush the
process but what I thought about was why
do I get depressed you know
because it comes on without any
warning and I might be going along quite
happily in life then all a sudden this
Cloud comes over me and I start thinking
oh dear I don't feel so happy today I
don't feel so
uh positive and yet I've got no reason
to feel negative about life or or to get
depressed nothing crucial has
happened yes sometimes uh there are
things that trigger it but in
general I get depressed and it it must
be creeping up on me without me noticing
it so this is
um a general thing that I personally
believe every human being uh goes
through around the globe um to find a
positive person that's positive all the
time and never gets depressed I would
think it's quite a
minority now the heading a bucket full
of of
genes if you've uh studied meditation
there's so many different ways of
meditating but but really you're trying
to just sit quietly and clear the mind
clear the mind so that you have nothing
in in your mind to keep the chatter
going of the voice in your head or the
visual
pictures and you're trying to become
just an empty vessel or that's my take
on
it so I urge you to study and find a
meditation that works for you and
then what I'm about to tell you now it
almost contradicts meditation but you
need the tools of meditation to help
yourself um
find the gene that is you so I I'll just
put my own name in
there so if I don't know why I get
depressed and there's no reason for it
then I started
studying my relatives my the people who
have been in my life my aunts and uncles
my
parents and I started realizing that
when somebody says how much you know as
a baby oh yeah you he looks like his
grandfather or he looks like his mother
or all these things so so we
are an
accumulation of our ancestors and we're
carrying all those genes in in
us and therefore perhaps it was one of
them that is causing this uh depression
and and ton Gene may not be a depressive
at all but the overriding one like I
said I'll just I just name names make
some names up but and use my own but
let's say my Uncle George um who was
very depressive and
um in the end took his own life because
of depression and couldn't be satisfied
with living any longer
I jumped in front of a a train actually
rather a horrible way to go but you know
does am I carrying the gene of Uncle
George so I decided that uh I would calm
myself down get my breathing nice and
constant smooth I would empty my mind so
I would sit in the chair
prepare for meditation close my eyes and
just sit and wait for my breath to be
really peaceful so I couldn't
hardly hear my breath or feel my breath
passing through my nose or my mouth
depending on at what stage I I'm at so
if I just show you that I go slowly
close the
eyes relax the sh ERS check the body for
any
tension and I do this and I'm opening my
eyes
again I do this um
until I get to the place that I'm
comfortable and knowing that I'm will
say in the middle of a seesaw where I'm
not in a meditative state but I'm not in
an awakened state in the room that I'm
chosen to sit sit
in at that point I think we all have the
voice in our head that talks to us and
as I said earlier pictures of things
come to us and it's all created in the
mind
so I decided the voice in my head that
isn't a voice at all it's your own voice
isn't it you know it's it's the voice
that you
you have in there it's not not not a
secondary thing that you've obtained and
um so I decided I'd have a conversation
with the voice in my head and I asked
why do I get
depressed and I have to ask it calmly
because I'm on the middle of the Seesaw
remember and I don't want to you know
tip it one way or the other I want to
just sort of just gently keep it as
still as I can but knowing that it's
going to move if I do
anything um dramatic or if I ask a
question that's going outside of the the
boundaries
of where the mind has to go off
searching for it then I'm going to
disturb the place I'm
at so I decided this is some time
ago that I would analyze Tony
me and think to myself what what don't I
like about
myself is there anything I like about
myself well you know my my partner tells
me that uh I'm a good person a caring
person I think of others and
um don't speak harshly about anybody in
particular and um
so she gives me
praise but can I accept the praise
perhaps I can perhaps I can't normally I
can't because I don't feel that I'm the
the person that she is portraying but
that's from my perspective from her
perspective itive I'm
okay and perhaps the same with you
listening to this perhaps you're okay to
others but you're not okay to
yourself
so if I was making like a shopping list
of ticks i' I'd think to myself well I
don't wish to harm anybody I'm happy
living in my own space and you start
building this shopping list of the good
things if something pops into your head
and you question it and you
think I thought I was good but a little
bit of uncertainty is popping into my
mind now about if I am that good so
perhaps look at that a little bit deeper
in a
moment there's no set time limit to this
and if you want to switch to looking at
the negatives that you put yourself
under you can think
of I'm going to just pick one um why do
I
get short tempered if somebody annoys me
and it comes with such a quick burst
that um they're quite surprised
how I may have been building it up in
their mind and yet I just like a Flash
come out with something
statement or something of
anger and then still under the Seesaw
calmness and analyzing
mind you you can look at it and you can
actually look at pictures of yourself
doing this being disruptive or not being
the person you you want to be really and
you don't like that about yourself you
don't like these um traits about
yourself so ask the voice in your head
and say where does this come
from where does
this evil disliked whatever word you
wish to put to
it
depressive where does this come into to
Tony's body
so this then started me
realizing that Tony's Jean is sort of
floating about somewhere within
me but it gets lost because it's only
one small
Jee and yet I've got Uncle George I've
got Uncle basil I've got Auntie Edith
I've got Auntie Irene I got my mother my
father I've got all these other genes
that are dominating Tony's Little
Gene so I have Tony's body but I may
have the features of one of my
ancestors parents
or whether you like yourself when you
look in the mirror or not that's
something that you you have to deal with
but taking on the gene pole th theory he
you've got Tony's Little Jean floating
about there and you've got all these
others lots and lots of jeans from all
your ancestors been slowly carried
down and placed in you from
birth
and so I decided to start saying
well where do I get my
depression so the pictures in my mind
started showing me different
relatives mainly uncles and aunties
perhaps my
parents and I narrowed it down to my
Uncle George because he was the most
depressive of the whole
family so I was able to find a home for
the depression
and I decided that Tony's Gene must
become a larger Gene in the Jean Pool if
I'm going to carry it around for the
rest of my life then I need to make
Tony's Jean
stronger
than Uncle George Uncle basil a the
Irene you know my father my mother I
must make Tony's Jean
bigger more dominant so I can call
upon the person
that I've been told is a kind person
caring person because I I it's not that
I want to be that person but I am that
person and if I am that person then I
need to make that person stronger
because I don't like the other genes
that cause me disruption
I don't like them because I know in my
heart of hearts that's not
me so I'm hoping this is making sense to
whoever's listening to
this but try to
find the gene pole that you carry within
yourself and try working out what you
don't like about yourself and search
with when you're in this middle
meditative
State and that place you should be able
to think very clearly and to find out
who you really
are from that point
on every time something comes along that
disturbs you and disrupts the the good
Gene the Tony gene or whatever your name
is try to make that Gene the one that
starts coming to the four front of your
mind and try to work on making that Gene
stronger you do have in my opinion we
all have a bucket full of
jeans this
bucket has so many jeans because
ancestries go back time over many
generations
and we don't know the generations before
our uncles and
aunts you may have
known uh your
grandfather but it's not often that we
can go back too many
generations some people follow a family
tree and they research and the
information they get is normally about
the person and you can do that if you
you so wish I don't follow that theory
I'd rather follow um and give it time
that I have available in
myself so I hope this
helps
um so in brief if there's things you
don't like about
yourself and you question if that is
really you that is this disruptive
person or if
you're a kind person and your Gene is a
disruptive one I would hopefully not be
encouraging you to become the disruptive
person because I think that who I'm
speaking to will only be people that
will want to find a better you find your
Gene make that Gene
stronger please uh always make comments
if you wish to to this film contact me
if you know how to contact me and let me
hear your point of view and if I can
help you more I
will I still struggle I still get
depressed but I do know that I have
tools on how to look and analyze it if I
want to be depressed and fester in that
depression and make it last longer then
I know that Tony's doing it
then um I can I can criticize myself and
say why are you holding on to this
depression is it because you want
attention is it because you want
somebody to say nice things there could
be all manner of points to your M
makeup but by analyzing yourself I'm
sure that the journey will become more
peaceful the dep Impressions hopefully
will become
shorter you will become a more glowing
person and at least you'll know how to
find the Tony Gene in yourself rather
than just be the smallest Gene in the
bucket thank you for your time